let's think we've been doing trig in
advance in extension one
quite a bit recently right and what we
mean by trigonometric
expansions is to say if you have like
not just sine of
an angle like 30 degrees or pi on four
or something like that
or sign of a single thing like x or y or
theta
if you have actually a compound angle
inside your function
right something like say which i'm not
going to write there we'll write it down
on the next line because we're going to
use it something like
this right we can actually
expand this guy out it's not as simple
as sine a plus sine b
if only but that's not how trigonometry
works we get this much more complicated
result over here
can you quote for me what it is you go
ahead ariana yeah
yeah yeah calvin do you want to help her
out
um yes
very good okay so if you um haven't got
that down you should write it
this particular result by the way on the
reference sheet but you'll use this
enough at least i hope
that you won't need to refer to that
anymore though it's nice having a
security blanket
now i'm going to ask for a show of hands
here i will not put you on the spot and
ask you to actually do it but i'm just
curious to know how many of you
have an idea of this how many of you
could say to me
i know why this is true i could explain
it to someone else and prove
not that it you know it is true and
accept it but i can show you why anyone
any takers i see one
two one and a half anyone else
okay interesting thank you hands down
what i want to say to you
firstly is that should unsettle you
just a teeny little bit okay throughout
mathematics especially when you look at
something like that there are some bits
where
especially when you first learn it you
just accept it you're like
okay you know mr and mrs lee's they've
never lied to me before i'm just gonna
take this as given right
um but one of the things it's actually
one of the design principles
underneath this entire course is that
every result you ever get handed
you know enough mathematics to prove it
for yourself and not just
trust someone else a textbook a teacher
whatever that it must be true
now you actually have i hope been shown
some form of a proof some derivation it
probably had some weird triangles maybe
the unit circle in it
um it's a bit of a complicated mess is
what i'm trying to get at it's why so
few of you
actually can say oh yeah i know right so
what we're going to do is we're going to
prove this result
and all the rest of them as well
remarkably quickly
using complex numbers so what i'm going
to do is take you back to
de marvelous theorem right so we've got
this guy here
cos a theta plus i sine theta
to the power of n equals
this guy here
we're going to use this as an example of
how to get to it won't be this one
first but it's going to be an example of
this
that you'll see how quickly it comes out
of our use of complex numbers right
so simple example right this guy here
it's a bit of a mess so i want to try
and
come up with a simpler version of it
right so i wonder if you can imagine
with me what would happen if
both of the angles the a and the b what
if they were the same angle
like what if they were the same size
okay so this is a particular version
of sine a plus b where if we if we
call both angles say equal to i don't
know
alpha okay if i made them the same then
you'd have
alpha plus alpha so that'd be sine 2
alpha do you agree
now hopefully you can interpret this
line well enough to say if i just
substitute alpha
into everywhere i see a and b you'll get
a result out okay so this is what we
call
a double angle trigonometry expansion or
double angle formula
now what i want to get to like i know
you can already do that just by putting
it in there okay but you don't know why
this is true so i want to try and get it
why and we're going to use this to get
there okay how will i use this line
de marvin's theorem to try and get a
result for this
what am i going to need to substitute in
have a think
have a look look at this line and where
i could potentially find
this guy i'll just put it to you
rhetorically right
do you think you're going to get this
guy easily and nicely from that term
right
there probably not because it's it's the
wrong trig function
right so it's like okay well i'm going
to eliminate this guy i guess that
knocks out this one as well what about
this one is it easy to get this
out of this hmm are some people are
suggesting yes
i'm going to say yeah we could but it
will take more work i feel like there's
an easier candidate
on my equation right isn't it easy to
get sine 2 alpha
from here look at this there's like an
angle and it's being multiplied by
something already right i just need to
choose the appropriate
thing to multiply which is two right
so let's use demarva's theorem by
demand for theorem
and what i want you to do is i'm going
to pause remember it
i want you to quote it um i want you to
put in
the right number and the right angle to
get a two alpha
up in there okay it's going to mean you
have to substitute a few things
elsewhere in the equation as well
and then we're going to pull out a trick
we keep on using because it's so
phenomenally useful right
you're going to get some real stuff and
some imaginary stuff on this right hand
side
and because this is a sufficiently low
power right
you can actually expand this guy out
once you substitute that power in
and once you do that once you expand it
out you will get some real stuff
and some imaginary stuff now if this is
true if these things really are equal
then all the things that are real here
should be equal to all the real things
that are here
and the same should be true of the
imaginary things does that make sense so
i'd like you to
go ahead do the substitution you expand
out and then do your comparison
do all the lines and see what you end up
with remember where we're trying to go
and call me over if you've either got a
problem or you think you've got a result
off you go
so i see a bunch of you have gotten
there which is great
right let me just for those of you who
are floundering a little bit i'm not
sure where i'm going let me help you out
okay
what have i done line one i have quoted
demarva's theorem but what i've done is
i've put in a particular value for theta
and a particular value for
n my n is two you can see here
one two three times and then instead of
thetas i have alphas just to indicate
like i'm looking at a specific angle
here not just some general angle
so there's my substitution straight into
the formula and then
from this first line to the second line
i didn't have much to do on the right
hand side
uh and there's a good reason for that
right the right hand side already has
the thing that i'm
after this guy here sine 2 alpha i'm
just going to highlight it there right
this is the thing i'm actually i've been
interested in from the beginning right i
want to know what this thing is equal to
okay now i can actually say
and i hope you wrote this down by the
way comparing
real and imaginary parts to get to this
sign to alpha which which of these does
it represent on the right hand side the
real of the imaginary
have a look at the thing that's attached
to the front of my sign to alpha that's
an eye right so it's the imaginary part
that i'm particularly interested in
to try and get an answer to this so what
is the imaginary part here well i
actually already have it
on the left hand side even if i haven't
finished simplifying
you can see that i squared there because
we're squaring i it's going to take me
back into the
real world so therefore this bit here is
the one
i'm interested in do you see that so i
can just say sine
2 alpha remember the imaginary part
actually doesn't have
the i attached to it when i write that
equals 2
sine alpha cos alpha now
why does that make sense of what we
started with above well if we just did
the substitution from here
which we didn't know why it was true you
get cos alpha sine alpha plus
sine alpha cos alpha the same thing so
you got two of them right so you're like
sweet it works okay
now what's great about this is two
things number one um
ninety percent of you said this i'm fine
with and i've no idea
why it works right but i hope you're
able to trace back in your mind by going
back through this thing right
well this is true because i've got it
from here and this is true because i got
it from here
this is true because i got it from here
which i got from exponential form and so
on you have a strong foundation
to live on that's the first thing which
i want to point out i'm actually going
to point out three things
second thing i want to point out is you
never had to do any
diagram or geometry or geometric
reasoning here
because all the geometric reasoning is
baked into
the results that we started with right
all of these and you go all the way back
we've been doing trigonometry and
drawing diagrams on the complex plane
all the way through this topic so it's
kind of like you get that logic
for free just by quoting a line like
this right
and then the third last thing is you get
a result as a bonus
right because this is the real and the
imaginary parts together i haven't
touched
the real part right but i set out to try
and find out what sine 2 alpha was
but now we get cos 2 alpha for free
it's right here right it's the real part
which they do a teeny bit extra work
this is real cos squared alpha we kind
of alluded to before i just didn't say
what it was equal to
this is also real right what's that when
you simplify it
it's minus sine squared alpha right
there
so the imaginary sorry the real parts
give me cos
2 alpha equals cos squared
minus sine squared we could have started
there but there you go that's another
result it just comes for free complex
numbers
it's so good okay now